وموسكو لواشنطن انسانيتكم زائفة
وانتم تكذبون كما تتنفسون. مفرمة
اللحم الاوكراني اعلنت عريسها
الجديد وكييف تنفي. امريكا تعترف
بسبب تقديم المساعدات العسكرية
لاوكرانيا ويا له من سبب غريب.
جيش اوكراني جديد لمهمة وبايدن
يكرم زيلنسكي بحزمة مساعدات
جديدة. الدول الغربية تستعين
بالصين وتطالب بكين بعدم التحرك
عسكريا. ها يا للتناقض ونيران
الحرب السودانية تشتعل من جديد
والقضاء الفرنسي يقول كلمته في
لبنان والضحية مدير المصرف. ضربة
روسية موجعة. الارض تضيق ذرعا
بالاوكرانيين. يشددون الخناق
وقوات بوتين تتمدد على الارض.
وبعد ان اعلن مؤسس مجموعة فاغنر
الروسية ان القوات الروسية فرضت
سيطرتها الكاملة على مدينة
باخموت هنا بريجوجن يصرح انه
سيسلم باخموت اعتبارا من الخامس
والعشرين من مايو للجيش الروسي
اي بعد خمسة ايام من السيطرة
عليها لتبدأ فاغنر في سحب
وحداتها من باخموت للاستراحة
واعادة الترتيب. وكان مهمتهم هي
السيطرة على المدن وتسليمها فورا
فان هي الوجهة القادمة. وبرغم
الاعلان الروسي نفت كياب سيطرة
مجموعة فاغنر على كامل باخموت.
مؤكدة ان المعارك الشرسة لا تزال
مستمرة في المدينة حيث اعلن
الجيش الاوكراني تصديه لثمانين
هجوما روسيا في باخموت. وفي
باخموت وحدها تجاوز عدد الوفيات
الف وفق العديد من الوكالات التي
كانت تعلن وقت المعركة ان العدد
اليومي للقتلى يتجاوز المائة من
الطرفين لذلك سميت بمفرمة اللحم
او طاحونة اللحم البشري. ليعلن
الغرب اعترافه اخيرا. وبتقرير
عسكري غربي للمعهد الملكي
للخدمات المتحدة في لندن انه تم
رصد تحسن كبير في اداء مختلف
افرع القوات الروسية خاصة وحدات
والدفاع الجوي. وبحسب التقرير
يشكل هذا التحسن تحديا للهجوم
المضاد الذي تعد اوكرانيا لشنه.
اي ان موسكو رفعت من قوة ادائها
قليلا لتختبر قوة اوكرانيا في
هجومها المضاد. على الجانب الاخر
اعلنت الادارة المدنية والعسكرية
في كييف انها صدت الليلة الماضية
هجوما جديدا شنته مسيرات روسية
على العاصمة الاوكرانية وادى الى
سقوط حطام كييف من دون تسجيل
اصابات. ولكن تسبب الحطام
باندلاع حريق على سطح مبنى سكني
دون ذكر الخسائر. بينما قال
العقيد الكسندر رئيس المركز
الصحفي لمجموعة قوات شرق ان
عناصر المجموعة تصدوا لمحاولة
استطلاع قتالية للقوات
الاوكرانية بمنطقة نوفوسي لوكا
على اتجاه دونيتسك الجنوبي.
لتتجه اوكرانيا لتجنيد جيش من
المدنيين وحدات النخبة بما يسمى
بكتيبة ارتان. وذلك ضمن
استعداداتها للهجوم المضاد
المرتقب. وتعمل وحدة في
الاستخبارات الاوكرانية على
تدريب هذه القوة التي حددت
مهمتها باختراق الخطوط الروسية
واستعادة الاراضي التي ضمتها
موسكو. ومن معارك الارض الى حرب
المساعدات حيث صرح مستشار الامن
القومي في البيت الابيض جيك
سوليفان بان الولايات المتحدة
عند تقديمها عسكرية لاوكرانيا
فهي تسعى الى الا يؤدي تصعيد
التوتر الى نشوب حرب عالمية
ثالثة. ها يا له من سبب غريب حقا
وهو عكس ما تقوله موسكو تماما
والتي تقول ان المساعدات
العسكرية ستتسبب بمواجهة مباشرة
وحرب عالمية. وهنا يظهر احد
الاسباب التي قد تشعل المواجهة
المباشرة ليعود سوليفن مرة اخرى
ويقول ان واشنطن ستقرر مع
حلفائها مواعيد تسليم طائرات
حربية لاوكرانيا واعدادها لترد
صاحبة الردود اللاذعة المتحدثة
الروسية ماريا زاخاروفا بقولها
ان واشنطن تبدي انسانية زائفة
وتضلل الاخرين بالقول انها لن
تمنح طائرات اف ستة عشر
لاوكرانيا الا بشرط عدم
استخدامها لضرب روسيا. وبالعودة
الى حرب المساعدات فهو الامريكي
جو بايدن يعلن عن حزمة مساعدات
عسكرية لاوكرانيا بقيمة ثلاثمائة
وخمسة وسبعين مليون دولار وذلك
خلال وجوده في هيروشيما في قمة
مجموعة السبع وفق رويترز. وذلك
بعد وصول الرئيس الاوكراني
فولودي ميرزلانسكي ليحضر قمة
السبع ايضا. من جانبها اعلنت
رئيسة المفوضية الاوروبية ارزولا
فوندر لاين ان حزمة عقوبات
الاتحاد الاوروبي الحادية عشر
ستضم اكثر من تسعين شركة حول
العالم. لننتقل الى حرب الانتقام
الروسي. يقول احد الامثال
العربية ان الانتقام بعد سنة
يعتبر تسرعا بل الانتقام طعام
شهي يقدم على طبق بارد. حيث
اصدرت وزارة الداخلية الروسية
مذكرة اعتقال بحق مدعي المحكمة
الجنائية الدولية الذي كان قد
اصدر مذكرة اعتقال بحق الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين بحسب وكالة تاس.
فمن يعتقل من اليوم؟ التلاعب
بالاعصاب الصينية. الصين محور
الاهتمام الغربي هي عقدة
الامريكان وقضيتهم للحاضر
والمستقبل وهي قبلة التجارة
العالمية التي تتملق لا اوروبا.
فمن جهة هنا دعت مجموعة سبع بكين
في بيان صدر خلال لقاء القادة في
هيروشيما الى الضغط على روسيا
لتوقف العسكري ولتسحب فورا وبشكل
كامل وغير مشروط قوات من
اوكرانيا ومن جهة اخرى شدد قادة
دول مجموعة السبع على انهم
يعارضون انشطة العسكرة التي
تمارسها الصين في منطقة اسيا
المحيط الهادئ لكنهم اكدوا ايضا
ارادتهم بناء علاقات مستقرة مع
بكين. فيا لتناقضكم يا هؤلاء
تطلبون الشيء وضده فاما ان
تكونوا اصدقاء للصين او اعداء لا
داعي للتملق والتهديد في الوقت
ذاته. وهنا ترد بكين مبدية
استياءها الشديد ازاء البيان
الذي نشرته مجموعة السبع. وحذرت
سفارة الصين في بريطانيا دول
مجموعة السبع من ان اي اقوال او
افعال تضر مصالح بكين ستقابل
باجراءات مضادة قوية وحازمة.
الاحداث والتطورات. بعد يوم واحد
من القمة عربية اندلعت اشتباكات
عنيفة في السودان بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
باستخدام الاسلحة الثقيلة
والطيران الحربي الذي استهدف
تجمعات للدعم السريع في العاصمة
الخرطوم وسمع دوي انفجارات في
المنطقة. اعلن وزير الداخلية
اللبناني ان السلطات ستنفذ مذكرة
الاعتقال التي اصدرها الانتربول
بحق حاكم مصرف لبنان المركزي
رياض سلامة اذا قرر القضاء
اللبناني الامتثال لها. بعد ان
سقطت بيد القوات الروسية. برأيكم
ما هي الوجهة القادمة لقوات
فاغنر?